[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
first amendment attorney and top
constitutional law expert floyd abrams
weighs in on possible prosecution for
president trump
i think it's a very very close case
plus
later available grand jury's decision to
indict the bar owner seen here
accused of hitting a sheriff's deputy
with his car the lesser offenses he's
facing
and why he wasn't indicted for assault
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law on crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
former president trump's in peacetream
trial in the senate is set to begin on
february 8th
but a lot are wondering if he could also
face criminal charges
so anjanette levy spoke with a top
constitutional law expert and father of
the founder of law and crime network
yeah brian this discussion really has
nothing to do with impeachment that is a
totally separate proceeding
now many people have pointed to that
speech on january 6 that president trump
gave and they say that he incited the
crowd
and could be charged for it but first
amendment expert and lawyer floyd abrams
says the situation
may not be that clear-cut
on january 6 president trump claimed
before a crowd of tens of thousands that
the election
had been stolen you'll never take back
our country
with weakness you have to show strength
and you have to be strong
but president trump also said i know
that everyone here will soon be marching
over to the capitol building
to peacefully and patriotically make
your voices heard
violence followed at the capitol to date
dozens have been charged
some have suggested trump could face
federal charges of inciting insurrection
floyd abrams is the country's preeminent
first amendment lawyer
he represented the new york times at the
supreme court
over publication of the pentagon papers
and reporter judith miller in the cia
leak investigation
the law on this is a lot less clear than
a lot of experts are saying it is
and that's because the brandenburg
case which is a you know wonderful
speech protecting case brandenburg v
ohio started in cincinnati in 1964
when ku klux klan leader clarence
brandenburg
invited a tv station to film a rally
brandenburg spoke about exacting what he
called revengeance
against african-americans jews and those
who supported them
brandenburg was convicted of advocating
violence under ohio's syndicalism
statute
the case ended up at the u.s supreme
court in 1969
where his lawyer argued the statute
violated his first amendment rights
the film was taken on a remote private
farm
in which apparently there is no evidence
whatsoever that these people were not
invitees present on that farm uh
by authority of the ownership of the
farm but
in this case it is not someone else
contacting the television edwards
it is clarence brandenburg himself who
contacts the
television newsman himself brandenburg
won
which led to broad protections for
speech and the brandenburg test
which includes evaluating whether speech
causes imminent lawless action
or is likely to incite such action in
trump's case abram says he was
telling them to go and he would go
with them he never used the words
you know take down the capital but but
he used a lot of incendiary language
uh about something which was literally
about to occur
i think that that there's a really
strong argument
that that there was eminence and
likelihood here
i don't know what the answer is and i'm
not sure
somebody could prove that the answer was
he wanted this to happen
that his intention in saying these
things
was lawless conduct
and so that's one of the elements
and that's why i think it's a very very
close case
abram says trump invited his supporters
to washington
when liz cheney said that he lit the
match
that's not wrong it really isn't wrong
to say that he just may not have
lit it completely since it's a match
at the capitol but abrams says since
this is a close case
he doubts trump will be prosecuted for
incitement
it's a hard case it can too easily
sound like a political case um
uh i i doubt if there's gonna be
appetite
to do that i mean people who would want
to do that the most
are the people he's happiest out of town
i don't see any great public purpose
uh in having a case sure to go to
the supreme court which won't be there
for another year or so
and any criminal charges that would come
out against
the president his top advisors or anyone
who organized that big rally on january
6 would likely come out of a grand jury
investigation by the federal government
lawyers seem to be split on whether or
not that will actually happen
brian thanks anjanet joining us today is
defense attorney adam conta and terry
austin adam
brandenburg is just one of many first
amendment cases do you see this or
any other case protecting the president
or do you i know
well like everyone else are you kind of
split as to whether or not he'd be
prosecuted
yeah i mean come on you just talked to
an international expert on this cause
and he said i don't know it's a close
call
what am i gonna say definitively right
um but
no i mean if you look at what he said i
think what's important here that he
didn't mention
is it's not just about what you say it's
who you say it to
so this wasn't at a cpac uh rally full
of conservatives and suits and ties
you got a guy out there dressed as a
water buffalo calling himself the cue
shaman
in a group of people who've been told
that the election was stolen from them
and then you say hey get out there and
get down to the capitol and i'll see you
down there
yeah of course he lit the match and of
course he knew what was going to happen
but on the other side of that i could
very easily say ah yes but he said
peaceful
you have the right to say what you want
so i think this
uh all of this if you look at
brandenburg it is close and if it's
close as a defense attorney i think oh
well that's wiggle room that's
reasonable doubt
uh and so i think that this will better
be served if this heads to an
impeachment trial than
a criminal incitement trial i think this
this evidence is going to be very
impactful hopefully
to try to stop him from ever becoming an
elected official again
but i think it would be a very difficult
hurdle to uh to find criminal charges
here
i can see that terry real quick what do
you think i agree with floyd abrams
obviously and i agree with adam i think
that
impeachment will probably be supported
by this
information but i think as far as
bringing a separate trial that's
probably not going to happen and trump
might prevail as far as that goes yeah
we'll see where that goes bradenburg is
not the only case of course you've got
uh hesv indiana usv watts all that plays
in a part but we'll keep following that
if it does actually go to trial thank
you both still ahead on law and crime
daily courtroom claims against the
former president and his allies grow
plus why grand jurors in the brianna
taylor case are calling for the kentucky
attorney general to be impeached
next
[Music]
welcome back legal battles over the
trump presidency continue to mount
as terry austin explains there's a new
claim against one of trump's right-hand
men
brian former trump attorney and new york
city mayor rudy giudiani
is being sued for defamation by dominion
voting systems
the company alleges that giuliani
knowingly made
false statements that dominion stole the
election
even after he was sent a cease and
desist letter
from the company the company stated that
the harm to dominion's business and
reputation
is unprecedented and irreparable because
of how fervently
millions of people believe it dominion
is asking the court for 1.3
billion dollars in damages thus far
giuliani has not responded to the
lawsuit
thank you terry and now to kentucky
where three of the grand jurors in the
brianna taylor case are calling for the
impeachment
of kentucky attorney general daniel
cameron
cameron was tapped as the special
prosecutor for taylor's death she was
killed by louisville police officers
executing a warrant on her home last
march
the grand jurors were randomly selected
in jefferson county and heard three days
of testimony in september
they only returned an indictment for
former detective brett hankinson
for recklessly firing into a neighbor's
apartment cameron spoke at a presser
immediately afterwards
and the three grand jurors now say he
misrepresented the findings to the
nation
we presented all of the information and
they ultimately made a determination
about whether to charge in this instance
they
decided to indict detective hankinson
well what my role as the special
prosecutor in this case
was to provide the information and facts
to the grand jury
detective cosgrove and sergeant
mattingly
were justified in returning fire because
they were fired upon
the grand juror signed a petition
accusing cameron of abuse of office
breach of duties and failing to comply
with ethics the petition will go to the
kentucky house of representatives
and former federal prosecutor gene rossi
says it should be looked at closely
he gave the public he ran his mouth he
ran his mouth
and gave the public the impression that
they had presented homicide or
manslaughter charges
for all three all three officers that
was a lie a lie
and that's damning that he played
politics with the grand jury process
and he took over that case evidently
because he wanted to
take it away from politics but he
injected it into the court into the
grand jury room
couldn't said it better gene rossi back
for analysis his defense attorney adam
conte and co-host terry austin
terry this is a first for me a grand
jury looking to impeach an ag
but here i'm all for it what do you make
of the allegations though made by these
jurors
well you know i think it makes sense to
impeach him or do something there should
be some action against him
what they're claiming is that you know
he took part in
making this insurrection on january 6
happened by
having these incendiary robocalls i
don't know if that actually happened but
if it did then he should be impeached
for that he also obviously as gene rossi
was saying he breached the public trust
because he misrepresented to the country
what the grand jury was actually saying
and for that i do think he breached his
duty and for that i do
think he has some ethical obligation
that he should be
prosecuted for or at least he should be
sanctioned for
all right so the robocalls are maybe the
connection to this january 16th because
that was kind of
making me scratch my head adam breach of
public trust
abuse of uh office misrepresentation
those all make sense do you see those
charges
being strong and then kind of almost can
you comment on that january 6 part two
sure briefly uh i love this because
there's no accountability for
prosecutors
who don't present a case to the grand
jury in an appropriate way
so if nothing else this brings light to
the to the very real issue
of the amount of power and discretion
prosecutors have in charging these
incredibly serious crimes so let's take
a look let's say these granders are
saying whoa whoa whoa we weren't told
what we should have been told
that's incredibly important and i love
that we're taking a look at it here
as for the robo calls in january 6
listen he's a he's an official
he is part of the republican attorney
general association and they put out
really incendiary robocalls telling
marchers to to go down to the capitol so
he's got to take accountability of that
too he's one of the nine members of the
board for that
yeah it makes sense the we just got to
see where this goes there's some
interesting allegations and from day one
we said
this didn't sound right when he stepped
out in that presser thank you both
coming up on law and crime daily the sex
trafficking sting operation that rescued
dozens of missing children
plus while kyrin house is ordered to not
have contact with known white
supremacists
a judge's ruling after the break
a judge has ordered the accused kenosha
shooter to not associate with white
supremacists or drink alcohol while out
on bail
now 18 year old kyle renton house is
charged with killing two people
and injuring a third at a protest last
august prosecutors say rinton house was
seen drinking at a bar in wisconsin
just 90 minutes after his arraignment on
january 5th
he could legally drink there because he
was with his mother according to court
documents reinhouse posed for photos
with a group of men
flashing the okay hand gesture an
adopted symbol of white power for hate
groups
prosecutors say rin house was singing
the proud boy to anthem and drank three
beers while at the bar
a kenosha county judge has now modified
the conditions of rain house's two
million dollar bond
ordering him not to consume alcohol or
have contact with any person or group
known to harm or threaten others based
on their race beliefs or gender
back to talk spirits and supremacists
are adam conte and terry austin
terry this all stemmed from rent house
legally
drinking at a bar i gotta emphasize that
it was legally done
and posing with white supremacists like
i'm not a fan of them but
it seems legal is this decision too far
by the judge in your opinion
you know what brian while i think
britain house
should be prosecuted to the fullest
extent of the law
i do think that this decision went a bit
too far look i think it makes sense
that he shouldn't be fraternizing with
white supremacists that's what caused
the issue in the first place
but i think it's going to be hard to
keep him from doing that how do you show
that someone is a racist or isn't a
racist
and the other issue as far as the
drinking's concerned he was not breaking
the law his crime had nothing to do with
his drinking
so i do think that that's overreaching
and in fact the judge should not have
said
that he can't be allowed to drink
especially if he's doing it legally with
his mother
yeah adam we see this in our cases dwi
the judge says you can't drink
afterwards
if it's a hate crime maybe there's some
other additional requirements on your
bail or your bond
but this there's no association with
that i mean at this point say okay
maybe he's not allowed to drive maybe
he's not allowed to go to a strip club
all things he can legally do
uh at 18. am i just being ridiculous
here
uh i think you guys are out of your mind
uh we see
clients with minor cases all the time
like you just mentioned
drugs gwi they're not allowed to drink
it's part of the conditions because it
makes them
a less dangerous member of society it
reduces the risk of having them out in
society
this guy killed two people by accident
didn't kill a third tried to kill three
people
and a judge says hey i don't think you
should drink because clearly you're
going out
and associating with white supremacists
and getting
and getting boozed up 90 minutes after a
moment
i think the judge is fine for saying no
booze on this guy
this is such a case of two systems of
justice that this guy
is out on fail to begin with i cannot
believe you two think
that he should be able to drink on top
of this i i
i i agree i agree with the bond but none
of my homicide clients are not allowed
to drink alcohol when they're out that
was the only point that i was making but
i agree with you on the bond there adam
when we come back shocking video
captured a bar owner apparently hitting
a deputy with his car
so why did a grand jury decline to
indict we break it down
just ahead
authorities in los angeles say 33
missing children have now been safely
located
and rescued the multi-agency
investigation known as
operation lost angels found the children
during a human trafficking operation
the fbi says eight of the children had
been sexually exploited
two of the children were rescued
multiple times from a known commercial
sex trafficking location
one suspect was arrested on state
charges and asians say they're helping
to start new investigations
singer trey songz has been released from
jail following an altercation during the
afc championship
football game in kansas city the singer
whose real name is tremayne aldon
neverson
is accused of punching a police officer
and putting them in a headlock
kansas city police say fans complained
about a man not wearing a mask
and the man then refused to leave when
asked by private security and officers
that's when trey songs allegedly
attacked the officer charges have not
yet been filed
a new york city bar owner arrested for
violating coven 19 protocols
will not face charges for allegedly
hitting a sheriff's deputy with his suv
a staten island grand jury indicted
daniel presty of mack's public house
for unlicensed sale of alcohol and
running an unlicensed bottle club
pressy defied city and state orders
denying patrons from entering his bar
declaring an autonomous zone
surveillance video from the bar on
december 6
shows presti running to his jeep and
driving away with a deputy clinging onto
the hood
drove a hundred yards with the law
enforcement officer
clinging to the hood for his life
you don't attack them you don't attack a
law enforcement
enforcement officer who's doing his or
her job
and when you have someone who drives
their car
into someone could have killed him
hospitalizes him how dare
you what signal are you sending
the staten island district attorney says
presti opted to testify
during the grand jury proceedings presti
said publicly
he did not realize it was officers that
were after him he had been arrested on
charges of assault
menacing and reckless driving fleeing a
police officer
he now only faces minor offenses
back for analysis is adam content and
terry austin
now i practice in brooklyn we i think
i've said this multiple times on this
show
i know adam kanto personally from seeing
him in the courts but adam you started
your
legal career as a public defender in
staten island i thought this was crazy
that they couldn't indict an officer
you seem to think it's not as crazy why
is that
well this is an age-old game of rock
paper scissors for staten island
uh and staten island is a wonderful
place i did start my career there
uh and i love staten island for in a lot
of reasons
they're incredibly conservative uh they
love
police and firemen there a lot of police
and firemen and nypd live on staten
island
so but let's take a look at the history
of staten island justice for just a
moment
eric garner the biggest case in maybe
new york city recent history
couldn't get a cop indicted there for
choking him out and essentially
murdering him
uh an innocent black man just selling a
loose cigarette
what we've now learned is that the only
thing that the uh grand jurors of staten
island
love more than cops is a conservative
white guy who's a small business owner
because if this was eric garner behind
the wheel of that car
there would not be this story there
would be a black man indicted
for attempted murder on an officer case
closed
no questions asked i do not doubt that
for one
second so this tells me that not only
are there two systems of justice
in uh in america there's a very tiered
system of justice in staten island
unfortunately
that's how i see it now terry as bizarre
as i may perceive this
this is 100 legal right like this can
happen
well yes it can happen and while i love
governor cuomo i
i do agree with adam i think we have two
systems of justice
here and obviously the grand jury
believed daniel presti
he didn't think that these were police
officers he was running down he thought
he was
trying to save his life and the grand
jury believed that
and they said to themselves look i think
your license
should really be up for debate because
you were breaking covet 19 rules
but frankly we don't think that you were
trying to run down a police officer so
you know i think things happen
differently in staten island for
different people absolutely adam terry
thank you and thank you for joining us
here at long crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you